harry said he said
an entire galaxy can pivot around the
actions of an individual
so then you are one of those individuals
right
harry is guiding you to keep the plan on
course
because i'm what
special
hey guys pete here today i'm gonna do
another book to show video for
foundation i'm gonna cover episodes five
and six it's getting a little bit harder
to do this there's a lot of changes a
lot of things that are only in the show
and i'll cover those but the real
problem is that most of the things
they're drawing from the story are
connected to spoilers for the big
picture so i'll do what i did in my last
video like this i'll talk about things
that have been passed up in the book
already and then i'll give you a second
spoiler warning and just talk straight
book spoilers in the last few minutes
there has been a lot more information
about what the creators are trying to do
we had the ama on reddit from the
showrunner david goyer which gave us a
lot of insights into what he was
thinking about and then there are the
official podcasts where they talk about
specific details from each episode
the fifth installment of the show opened
with a flashback to gayle's time on
synax this had something that was pulled
from a different character who was an
important part of the prequels we
learned that gail's education and
everyone else's on the planet had been
interrupted when the seer church took
over and started to cleanse the
intellectuals then she got a hold of
callie's writing and appeared to learn
advanced math on her own to solve the
abraxas conjecture and make it to
trantor this sounds similar to a
character named hugo who harry seldon
encountered when he visited the lower
levels on trantor he found him working
in the heatsinks which is this really
brutal job class wise these workers were
considered the lowest of the low and
don't have access to quality education
in their interactions harry realized
that hugo was a brilliant mathematician
even though he never studied it he had
an innate ability to understand really
complex ideas and over the years he
became the second most important psycho
historian behind seldon himself in the
ama david goyer mentioned that gale was
a combination of two characters and this
seems to point to her absorbing hugo's
role it's a little confusing because
everything important the character did
happen before the original trilogy
started but i think the end of episode 5
gives us an idea how these two might
still work together even after harry's
death in the books the last thing gail
did was go to terminus right before
harry died after the encyclopedist had
already been there for a while there was
no slow ship rach and harry weren't
there there was no murder there was no
cryo sleep and of course there was no
waking up on a ship where she catches a
glimpse of a glitching hologram of harry
we're still in the teasing stage of that
unfortunately we don't really know what
was going on there yet but personally i
think harry did die but there's
something going on where his
consciousness will continue and we'll
see him do some of the things he did
towards the end of the prequel as far as
setting things up at the same time that
things are happening on terminus and
back on trantor in the books harry
played a continuing role but he was only
involved in that he pre-recorded
messages that would help to explain
things to members of the foundation over
the years so things are going in a
different direction for sure but there
is an opportunity for gail to do some of
the things hugo did which were essential
to harry's plan
on terminus things have been feeling
pretty different compared to the books
all the way around but we did get a
couple of things that were recognizable
in the last two weeks
in my last video i already went into how
the salvor character and the vault were
different and talked about how cleon
attacking and acrion really changed
things up those things all continue to
go in their own directions in episode
five and six but before we get into that
i just want to mention again what goyer
said about salvor i went over this in my
season 2 ama video but in case you
haven't seen that he said that our
salbore is not the fully formed salvor
of the books this is her origin story
we're picking her up a good 20 years
before the salvor that appears in the
encyclopedist
she hasn't yet internalized the teaching
of her father etc so as i said before in
the show we heard the saying violence is
the last refuge of the incompetent they
changed it so that it was her father's
saying and now that we've seen him die
and that seems like it's going to be a
big turning point for the character it's
a safe bet that she's going to adopt
this as her way of being going forward
once she gets the whole idea of revenge
for his death out of her system the
showrunner also ensured fans in the ama
that there were no chosen one characters
in the story but that they were playing
with the concept of people feeling like
they might be and other people believing
they might be that seems to be directly
related to what we saw going on between
salvor and hugo after his death in the
last two episodes we saw what looked a
lot like a crisis as we watched
enacrion's plan unfold in the show's
version of events they're desperate
because of cleon's attack and their
quest for revenge their plan for that
includes getting a hold of an actual
imperial soldier which we saw them get
in dorwan the whole thing left terminus
stuck in the middle as they're an
outpost of the empire and they were used
as bait in the books the first crisis
was also with an acrion but the
political situation was completely
different they were starting to act
independently from the empire and they
were starting to take over the other
planets in their general vicinity book
salvor and the encyclopedist were facing
a military threat but it never got to
the point of terminus city being
attacked one thing the show did
introduce that came from the books was
the invictus there the ship played a
large role in the second selden crisis
which happened a few decades later when
salvo was older from that it looks like
the show's combining the first two
crises together or at least some of the
elements so it's an imperial ship in
both places but the emphasis on it being
a planet killer seems more important to
the anacrions on the tv show if they can
take control of it they might be able to
do some real damage to trantor maybe
even destroy trantor which would be a
huge blow for the empire so we'll have
to see where they go with it it's not
exactly the same as how it's introduced
in the book so we'll see what happens
to come back to this idea that there are
no chosen one characters in the show the
big thing that has made salvor seem
special is that she's able to approach
the vault and doesn't feel the effects
of the gnoll field ever since the second
episode aired i've been guessing that
the zygote that gail and rach put into
storage was a sign that they'd end up
being salvor's parents her having
visions that include rach seem like
further evidence and really there hasn't
been anything to make me change my mind
as more people are starting to come
around to this i've seen an interesting
theory in the comments a couple of times
that might turn out to be correct the
visions seem to be coming from the vault
which was always going to be there
waiting for the encyclopedist when they
arrived gail was supposed to be with
them and it's possible that harry's plan
involved her being the one who could
access the vault when the time came if
salvore does end up being her daughter
then it could be some sort of biometrics
or dna related security something like
the fence around terminus that allows
her access and gives her that connection
we're not sure how the visions work yet
but they could be tied to harry's
consciousness if that's still around and
this is something that i'll come back
around to in the book spoilers section
everything else that's been going on has
been related to the cleons which don't
appear in the books at all like i
mentioned last time the young cleon
being different isn't directly related
to anything that happened in the books
and in the ama there was mention that he
incorporated some of leopold the first
story but there's nothing i can really
say about that that wouldn't be future
spoilers the luminous church is also a
show only thing it seems like they serve
to show that the cleons don't control
every part of their citizens lives
luminism offers people reincarnation a
chance to come back and live another
life their death is not the end and
although that can be useful to the
empire to keep people happy he has no
control over it so when we see halima
rising and bringing up this idea of
stagnation which is a really big part of
why the empire is falling it puts him in
an awkward situation and it reinforces
that idea to us as viewers what's most
interesting to me is the demmer zell
connection but again there's nothing i
can really talk about there that
wouldn't be future spoilers so i think
this is a good place to leave the book
to show section where i don't talk about
spoilers and this is your chance to
leave because i'll be spoiling some
future plot points from now until the
end of the video if you gotta go please
do like and subscribe on your way out so
i still feel like they combine salvor
with wanda and that she'll probably turn
out to be a mentalic but it's all a
little muddier now gail's taking on
hugo's story would make sense if she's
able to interact with harry and they
could come up with the idea of the
second foundation and get that going she
did tell rates the math was incomplete
perhaps that would be where they start
or it could be that rach was intended to
start the second foundation and that he
was going to helicon to recruit someone
or just start it there instead of
trantor since we have an active story on
the capital planet with the cleons
thinking that the vault was set up for
her and rach was supposed to be where
she is now seems to track but then the
mentalix and the founding of the second
foundation could go a couple of
different ways so we'll just have to
wait and see i had a feeling we wouldn't
see harry in the next episode after that
cliffhanger but he is in the thumbnail
of the next episode so we should get an
idea of what's going on soon it's funny
because demarzel is such a wild card at
this point people who've read the books
are thinking things like she started
luminism they see this religion it could
have been her because of her age it
would be possible or that she's behind
the changes that are happening with
cleon the 14th and again she is in
charge of the cloning program so you can
see it so yeah she could be she could be
all those things she definitely could be
i guess i just hope that she's not
behind every mystery that pops up other
than you know that she's literally
behind everything there's a real chance
of it getting worn out fast for those of
us who've read the series hopefully they
can keep us on our toes i guess is what
i'm saying i came away from the most
recent episode of the podcast thinking
there's something else going on
something outside of what we know from
the books but i have no idea where it's
heading gorier had previously said the
laws of robotics exist in the story but
that doesn't mean that demarzel is
currently bound by them in the podcast
he mentioned that she and then corrected
to say they because as a robot there's
no fixed gender had agency in the past
but now there's some programming
protocols in play which he didn't really
explain it does sound like there's
something going on there probably back
to the time of cleon the first and i'm
interested to see where that goes and i
will leave things there let me know in
the comments what you think about all of
this just be conscious to mark any book
spoilers please like this video if you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon